c'était le 4 juillet 2015 aux us à
boston et en voyant les lumières des
feux d'artifice tomber je n'ai pas honte
de dire que j'ai eu une petite pensée
pour le grand très grand
isaac du town car les magnifiques
couleurs 2000 peu n'était autre que le
chaînon manquant entre le quotidien des
hommes qui est aussi le monde très
terre-à-terre de la pomme et le royaume
divin des cimes
mais pour comprendre ce à quoi je pense
il me faut revenir autour des années
1630 au moment où trois géants des
sciences révélèrent un tas d'indicés
très intrigant
pour commencer aux pays bas rené
descartes fut une formidable découverte
mathématiques à savoir l'unification de
la géométrie de la classe antique et de
l'algèbre du monde arabe dès lors les
objets géométriques pouvait être
manipulé via des équations algébriques
pour newton la géométrie algébrique de
descartes et est du pain bénit
l'approfondît en inventant un tout
nouvel objet mathématique qu'on appelle
la dérive et cette invention est souvent
associé à la naissance des mathématiques
avancées
car enfin comment ça tu on a maîtrisé le
potentiel de l'infini en particulier
armé de sa nouvelle arme mathématiques
newton put enfin donner un sens précis à
des concepts auparavant tout comme la
vitesse ou l'accélération est ainsi
enfin les intégrer dans des équations
ensuite en italie
comme nous l'avions déjà dit non
seulement galilée a prouvé que les
objets tombent tous aussi vite mais il
caractérise a aussi la trajectoire de
ces objets en chute libre pour tout
objet
cette trajectoire était celle d'une
parabole l'étude de ces paraboles
conduisit newton à une conclusion assez
folle en dérivant la hauteur d'une pomme
par le temps par deux fois
hughton découvrit que la parabole était
la trajectoire d'une accélération
constante vers le bas c'était une
incroyable prouesse gagner les du town
avait unifié les chutes de toute chose
en montrant que qu'importe son poids sa
forme sa position sa vitesse qu'importe
s'il va vers le bas ou vers le haut tout
objet en chute libre gagne 10 mètres par
seconde vers le
à chaque seconde newton a là encore plus
loin avec une idée qui deviendra
incroyablement féconde les forces dit il
n'affecte ni les vitesses des objets ni
leurs positions elles ne peuvent
affecter que leurs accélérations
tel est le principe fondamental de la
dynamique que newton mathématicien en
vous savez f égal m à
enfin à prague le grand astronome et
johannes kepler analyse a minutieusement
les trajectoires des planètes dans un
modèle héliocentrique de l'univers
après des années à calculer comme une
bête kepper renonça au cercle et aux
épicycle qu'il remplaça par des ellipses
oui des ellipses mais pourquoi des
ellipses telle est la question que
l'astronome et mona et les pauses à un
newton 1 g newton répondit non
chaleureusement qu'il l'avait déduits de
sa théorie de la gravité et en
particulier du fait que la gravité des
croire en un sur la distance au carré
mais de quoi est il en train de parler
et puis comment est-ce que tu le sais se
demanda et des bas il y a 20 ans du town
répondit je l'avais calculé eh oui en
étudiant les trajectoires et les petits
que kepler newton avait déjà deviné la
loi de la gravité de l'univers mais il
n'avait pas pris le temps de le dire à
qui que ce soit et les en resta pantois
il supplie ya newton de publier sa
théorie du mouvement et de la
gravitation et promis de payer pour tous
les frais de publication
newton accepta et suite à travailler dur
très très dur pendant les 18 mois qui
suivirent il introduisit méticuleusement
ses nouvelles mathématiques au fur et à
mesure et paracheva un livre destin
historique ce livre commence par énoncer
quatre lois éternelles
les trois premières sont les lois du
mouvement
celle dont on a parlé dans un épisode
précédent et la quatrième est la loi de
la gravitation universelle de façon
cruciale
newton prouva que cette quatrième loi de
l'univers n'était pas plus divine dans
le ciel que sur terre les lois de
l'au-delà étaient les mêmes que celles
d'ici bas en particulier et de façon
contraire à tout intuition tout comme la
pomme la lune tongs constamment vers la
terre pour imager 7 priante réflexion
pour illustrer cette incroyable
l'unification de toutes les pièces de
l'univers en un monde régi par la seule
et unique loi de la gravitation de
newton consul expérience de pensée dite
du boulet de canon
mais moi je vais utiliser des feux
d'artifice
si un peu explose doucement alors ils
retombent selon une trajectoire
parabolique
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai trouvé ce spectacle si magnifique
s'il explose est fortement alors en
principe le feu pourrait retomber à
plusieurs kilomètres si explosé encore
plus fortement lors il pourrait même
aller à des milliers de kilomètres mais
comme la terre est ronde
la trajectoire du feu ne sera pas
parabolique
si le feu et explosé encore plus fort
allez pourquoi pas un peu de la physique
théorique alors le peu pourrait faire le
tour complet de la terre et suivrait
alors une trajectoire elliptique tout
comme une planète autour du soleil
cette expérience de pensée est vraiment
une pure merveille
elle montre bien qu'une seule et unique
loi de la gravitation suffisent à
expliquer à la fois la chute de la pomme
et laure bits des planètes
c'était une incroyable démonstration
mais surtout les physiques mathématiques
elle est désormais être à la fête
cette mathématisation des lois de la
nature était un projet absolument
fantastique qui pendant les siècles qui
ont suivi allez être consolidé par des
générations de très très grands génies
qui exploite air toujours plus le
potentiel monstrueux des mathématiques
et révélèrent ainsi un univers plus
contre intuitif plus mystérieux et plus
incompréhensible plus extraordinaire est
plus étranger que ce que newton lui-même
n'aurait jamais pu imaginer
newton écrivit je ne sais pas ce que je
suis aux yeux du monde
les à mes yeux me semble n'avoir été
qu'un garçon devant le long de la plage
et se divertissant de temps à autre a
trouvé un caillou plus lisse ou un
coquillage plus joli que d'ordinaire
alors que le grand océan de la vérité
s'étendait à l'infini inconnus devant
moi il ajouta si j'ai pu voir plus loin
que d'autres c'est en me tenant sur les
épaules de géants
nul doute que parmi ces géants newton
penser à des cartes galilée et kepler
troisième fois sur ça tienne je vous
propose un défilé plutôt les filles de
ma cage et que deux ou trois personnes
qui dans mes commentaires pour poser
cette question et je préfère pas y
répondre
parce que c'est des bouquets sur trop
boulet je préférais la partager avec
nous et pour faire réfléchir plus debout
de la question est la suivante si on
accélère constamment toujours avec la
même accélération est ce que l'on finit
par dépasser la vitesse de la lumière
je vous laisse réfléchir en fait déjà
donné l'importance
commentaire pour yeoh trouver la réponse
quelque part mais ce que vous avez à
faire c'est plutôt à réfléchir de vous
même lancé des pistes de réflexion avant
dans les commentaires si vous connaissez
la réponse à cette question ne donnait
pas de ce pôle est pas la réflexion des
autres cherchaient plutôt à aider les
autres à fléchir dans les commentaires
de but du jeu sur cette folle ce n'est
pas d'avoir un sur vingt ans que je me
trouve à une période d'examen ici de
plus du jeu c'est que l'on réfléchisse
tous ensemble à cette question pas si le
redis la dernière fois d'appareils des
lois de newton et holly sauce liste a
souligné le manque de rigueur de la
vidéo notamment parce que je n'ai pas
parlé de référentiels par première chose
à dire ça me fait super plaisir de
recevoir ce genre de commentaire c'est
exactement ce que j'attends de vous ce
que je veux que vous fassiez c'est bien
sûr regardé mes vidéos mais surtout
réfléchir à ces vidéos les critiques et
voir ce qui pourrait être amélioré ce
qui ce qui a été mal fait ce qui a été
bien fait aussi n'hésitez pas à
souligner les coins du côté positif et
si ça fait plaisir mais en tout cas
c'est ce commentaire même si dans la
forme n'était pas totalement plaisant
mais dans le fond il est absolument
génial ce commentaire et en particulier
la question de ce qu'on a le droit de
simplifier à outrance dans des vidéos de
vulgarisation scientifique est une
question qui me passionne normalement ça
fait vraiment longtemps que j'ai
réfléchi on ça fait quatre ans qu'elle
fout de la vulgarisation ce verrou
quatre ans que j'ai réfléchi à cette
question et suite à ses commentaires
j'ai décidé de faire une série de vidéos
sur scène ce forum qui va parler non pas
des mathématiques et des sciences
mais de la manière dont on parle donc on
fait dans ton pensent les mathématiques
et les sciences notamment je vais
revenir sur les imprécisions les erreurs
et les mensonges que l'on fait dans des
vidéos
de vulgarisation scientifique mais aussi
dans des cours en quarts notamment dans
ce cas il s'agit vraiment d'un mensonge
je pars me surnomme à bord bien sûr je
sais ce que c'est un référence à venir
j'ai été au lycée j'étais en prépa je me
suis fait taper sur les doigts pour ne
pas avoir parlé de référence y
accueillir dans mes copies de physique
et donc je sais je sais je connais
l'importance aux interférences et bien
sûr mais j'ai choisi de ne pas vous en
parler de faire un bon son choix
ambitions parce que le but de la vidéo
notamment était de ramener la théorie et
la pratique de montrer que la théorie à
la pratique sont sont très très proches
et que tout ce qu'on dit en théorie
s'applique à la pratique il me semblait
que lorsqu'on introduit ces histoires de
référence est alors qu'ils ne sont pas
si triviaux que ça eh ben on rendait la
théorie encore un peu plus obscurs et on
l'éloigné ainsi de leur pratique et
c'est ce que je voulais éviter dans la
vidéo précédent autre chose que
j'aimerais à signaler les lois de newton
sont vachement complètement la loi de
newton est fait ghalem et ultra
incomplète si on sait à peu près ce
qu'elle est mais a aucune idée de ce
qu'est f
newton ne nous donne pas de liste
exhaustive des faits nous dit pas
comment calculer les forces de la nature
en fête pour connaître les forces de la
nature à avoir une théorie de
l'électoralisme qui n'était pas bien sûr
à l'époque de newton donc par exemple
quand j'étais au lycée que j'apprenais
la force de réaction normale du support
pour moi c'est un truc complètement adam
qui s'articule très bizarre il y avait
du mal à justifier c'était juste là pour
s'opposer au poids de sorte que la
théorie colle avec une observation
j'ai toujours trouvé ça ultra visa et
j'espère que vous allez trouver ça
bizarre comme la théorie de newton est
incomplète dans le f
les mains on peut rentrer ce que l'on
veut aussi dire que l'on peut rentrer
les forces d'inertie d'entraînement une
fois qu'on a intégré les forces
d'inertie d'entraînement f égal et marc
est vrai même dans des référentiels non
galiléen du coup l'importance de ces
référentiels est discutable
bien sûr il ya encore plus que ce que je
viens de dire à dire sur f1 galéma et
les lois but
il est en effet assez bien notamment
j'ai dit plus de choses que ce que je
dis là dans les commentaires de la vidéo
précédente que vous allez savoir
bref en conclusion que j'adore cette
réflexion j'adore tout ce qui s'est
passé dans ce fil de discussion se
trouve ça super intéressant mais si
c'était à refaire je referais la même
vidéo je ne parlerai pas de référence
lir
c'est un mensonge par omission que
j'assume encore aujourd'hui et j'en
reparlerai dans une vidéo à venir
enfin pour être dessous des coûts de 4
présente moi choix et j'espère que vous
avez mais cette vidéo la prochaine fois
ça y est le pari d'un relativité
générale et des aristos ne savais
absolument génial c'est 38 la question à
laquelle j'aimerais que voit on touche
ici et c est ce que les astronautes sont
vraiment dans la pesanteur et pour vous
préparer je vous invite aussi à
réfléchir à la question qui j'avais posé
dans les commentaires de l'épisode
précédent pas savoir à ce que l'on peut
mesurer ou non le fait que la terre
tourne autour du soleil
ce mouvement de rotation à ce que ça
induit des forces ou des calculs on peut
mesurer sur terre je vous invite à
réfléchir par avant chaque fois si vous
avez aimé cet épisode jeu n'hésitez pas
à le leak et à le partager et à le
commenter
j'apprends énormément en lisant vos
commentaires ça me fait super réfléchir
et je vous en remercie énormément pensez
à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les
futurs épisodes et surtout prochaine est
génial et j'espère que je vous verrai la
prochaine fois c'est la formule de la
gravitation univers
elle qui permet de rendre compte à la
fois du mouvement des planètes et de la
chute des corps l'équation la plus
importante de l'histoire des sens
moderne et gagnent m